I thought it would be really fun since
Rob's not here
to get into a conversation about acting
oh man
oh that's a dig it's not even a veiled
dig what was the first time you
performed
maybe you didn't even realize that that
you were acting I think in in first
grade or kindergarten I I did a thing
where I like walked on and held like the
intermission sign and I remember holding
it upside down and everyone being like
oh that's so cute he got it backwards
but little me was like oh no I knew that
was going to be funny I did that on
purpose already trying to get laughs
like from day one that was your only
role and that play was holding yeah
coming out to be like intermission I
figured out how to make it about you
yeah because my mom
very well
[Music]